former u.s champion also a gold medalist
as well in the olympics and
showing that he can hang with the best
of them sam this was simply a great
tournament for you you beat up on what
you beat up on uh
two stars of the game you sacked the
queen on naca you sacked a queen on
wesley you drew fabi
you must be really happy with the kind
of tournament you played yeah i sort of
have mixed feelings because i believe i
could have won this tournament if i
played a little better at a couple
critical moments but also like i was
basically one of the lower rated players
and it doesn't play to my strengths in
terms of both the time control and the
fisher random element so to like make a
really a big score is completely
unexpected i never would have guessed i
would have scored like this so there's
both positive and negative but yeah i'm
gonna be wondering about the the things
that came particularly the one that bugs
me the most is that i saw the winning
move against mama jarv right after i
moved
well sam i gotta say a lot of players
might say yeah i could have won this
tournament if only i'd found a couple of
moves at the critical moments but peop
you got it done overall with what simply
cannot be anything but a great result
yeah no certainly overall i'm very
satisfied you know whenever you just
barely miss winning a tournament the the
first feeling is well what could i have
done better but of course on the whole
it was it was a fine it was a very good
result uh another one i mean it was it
felt like a weird tournament because i
almost felt like i only played five
games uh the
the two with wesley and hikaru were just
and uh that i won just very easily
without any kind of a fight and then i
also lay down without any kind of a
fight against maxime and gary so
all those games were like decided by
move ten and it didn't even feel like i
played them honestly so it just sort of
felt like you just get you know four ha
four buys to make you know two out of
four and then play five real games but
it was funny the the last five games i
really got to play a lot of chess which
was a lot of fun you mentioned before
that you don't feel
like it's natural for you to play rapid
chess uh that you're not as talented
maybe more you're the hard worker but we
saw a lot of spectacular chess from you
here well i think as you make the time
control faster it does sort of tilt the
balance in favor of uh those the more
talented in terms of hard work but i
still think rapid is
not that fast i mean there's a 10 second
increment i don't know from what the
increment was here but there was enough
it was fun it's only really when it gets
to blitz that it really starts to tilt
heavily i mean here it tilts a little
bit but i also think here the randomness
factor is enormous just because of the
fish around him but for example one
thing i was noticing was uh i was
scoring really well in positions where
the pieces were coordinating reasonably
well in the beginning of the game uh and
were the piece the positions were like
it was really looking ridiculous was
where these guys were just out playing
me uh so
but yeah uh the the one that would that
bothers me though is the mama jar of one
where i i missed the widow then i saw it
right after i moved of course i had like
15 seconds so but right after i moved i
saw it trust me nobody's gonna remember
that one we will remember this one this
was sweet queen takes on e5 this one is
it going down in your combination book
later somewhere in your life i mean it's
it's very easy it's just also very
aesthetically pleasing of course this is
not this one is not rocket science if
you give this to someone in puzzle rush
they'll see it's just a candidate moving
the game's over but it definitely was
very aesthetically pleasing i was happy
about that i i might not have won a
brilliant surprise with this but i may
win the beauty price so it definitely
was beautiful congratulations on a great
result we look to see you do some more
damage in wrapping uh this last game
against caruana who was winning who
missed more wins me or him
i'm pretty sure we both missed a lot i
mickey was better but i don't know that
it was so easy because i felt like at
some point i was busted and then i
thought at the end i should have won so
was i wrong about both of those i don't
i don't see i don't remember the the
engine giving any advantage uh at the
end for either of you okay so i didn't
have anything at the end then but uh but
we were we were paying attention to too
much stuff okay yeah
yeah but the engine doesn't say anything
about here after this d5 he's like still
admitted i thought i was winning but oh
maybe some 95 night before but it's 95
93 that's it well it's it's minus one so
still far from that yeah
no but amazing we'll get to queen and
we'll get to queen against rook note and
two puns
i think you're judging yourself a little
harshly yeah i don't know anyhow it's
all good um yeah but uh no this is a
great event so i certainly i'm glad i
proved that i could play with these guys
that in a format that i wouldn't think
normally suits me i'm certainly happy
with the result overall even if a little
disappoint that i couldn't win it in the
end all right and congrats to linear
absolutely well
thank you sam
that was in my opinion that was an
amazing tournament by sam i know he's
very hard with himself and it's one of
the